all right guys so uh before we go i want
to send you off with a little piece of
information that will change your life
forever in a segment we call blow your
mind
so this will blow your mind uh
we're all made of molecules
molecules
you
me
this guy everyone here just a bunch of
microscopic atoms bonded together i know
you know that
but when's the last time you thought
about that
matter is molecules that cannot be
destroyed it's just rearranged that's
what the universe is
so fellas your dick
isn't really a dick
it's just a bunch of molecules that used
to be other stuff
a shoe a mountain
possibly boobs
and your molecules have been around for
billions of years since the beginning of
time so the molecules in you right now
could have at one point been in abraham
lincoln's beer
or a triceratops taint
listen to me your face is made up of a
triceratops is tint
that's science mind blown
you